just what is quasi quartet gonna have to
do to try and sort out the public
finances well we have one answer for the
institute for fiscal studies we've got
their green budget it basically looks at
all of this stuff and here perhaps is
the most important chart it shows you
the national debt so the total amount
that the UK government owes and that has
built up over many many years a lot of
that's due to covid but here's the thing
we're looking through to the Future here
and what you can probably see from this
is that it was more or less flattening
and starting gradually to fall that's
gradually going down in the coming years
but here's what happened in the mini
budget the government basically added a
lot to it so whether it's the energy
price guarantee all of those other
measures reversing those tax increases
you can see that's going up and that's
the thing that markets are concerned
about certainly the ifs is concerned
about it as well and the big question is
how do you bring that down how do you
kind of get that slab down so that you
are bringing the national debt lower
well that costs a lot of money according
to the ifs and City who are looking at
these numbers 62 billion pounds needs to
be removed and where do you get 62
billion pounds from well it's a law lot
of money let me just show you for
illustrations some of the things you
could Castle change to get to it but
it's just illustration this stuff is
pretty controversial for instance
operating benefits by earnings so not
raising them in line with inflation it
means a real terms cut for those many of
those who are on benefits 13 billion
pounds you can get from that you can get
about 14 billion pounds by cutting your
investment spending but here's the thing
investment spending is one of the things
that generates growth and if this
government really is about growth growth
growth that doesn't seem like the
obvious thing to cut or finally you
could cut non-nhs or defense spending
their day-to-day spending that's
basically like austerity but if you cut
it by about 15 then you're talking about
35 billion pounds quite a lot of money
but none of these are very palatable
options the final option the one the
government would most like and everyone
would most like is to get growth the
more growth you have the lower that has
to be but here's the thing even if you
assume there's going to be perhaps 0.25
extra growth that's what city says is
possible you're still talking about 41
billion pounds you're still talking
about potential Cuts you're still
talking about potential austerity those
are the choices facing quasi-quartering
none of them particularly palatable but
that's where he stands right now